heads up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to the ray tracing series
okay so we're rendering a sphere great
but you know what's better than a sphere
two spheres what we're going to talk
about today is how we can have many
spheres in our scene and in fact what
even is a sin and how do we structure
that the theory behind rendering
multiple objects is rather simple if you
haven't already I encourage you to
actually think about it stop this video
right here and try and actually think
through how you would do this yourself
without me intervening and showing you I
think it's really important that pretty
much every step of the way in this Ray
tracing series you try and actually
think and do this work yourself trying
to figure out things for yourself even
if you end up with a worse solution is
always good so get into the habit of
doing that if you want to learn at the
moment inside our viewport we basically
have this definition of a camera that
shoots Rays into a specific Direction
and from a specific origin from a
specific point we also have
mathematically the description of this
single sphere all we do for each Ray is
just see whether or not it actually
intersects this sphere and if it does
then we take the character calculations
a step further to figure out like the
hit position and from that the normal
and all that stuff and then eventually
return a color if we dial back that
process a little bit and we just think
about what we actually do to work out
whether or not we hit the sphere we do
some math involving the Ray and then
this mathematical description of a
sphere which is really just its position
and its radius in fact we haven't really
touched the position of this sphere yet
we can't really move this sphere around
that's also something we'll talk about
today so with that Concept in mind if we
want to have multiple spheres in our
scene we just need to do that Ray versus
sphere intersection test multiple times
if we have two spheres in our scene then
for every Ray that we fire from the
camera we just need to see whether it
intersects sphere a or sphere B now if
that Ray intersects both spheres because
like one's behind the other one then we
need to figure out which one is closest
to the camera and that's the one that
we'll evaluate and that's it that's
really all there is to it obviously if
we don't hit anything we just return
like our background color if we do hit a
sphere then whichever sphere we hit
that's the one whose color will return
and do the lighting calculations on now
this is obviously like this simple case
for what we have here at the moment
which is a very simple Ray Tracer when
we get a little bit deeper and we have
for example translucent materials then
obviously we might want to render one
sphere in front of the other sphere like
if we go through glass we probably want
to keep going so that we see the sphere
behind our glass sphere but for now
let's keep things simple so if we take a
look at our code if we take a look at
our Trace Ray function this is the
function that's effectively drawing the
image we just saw there are two really
really important parts here there's the
first kind of Step which calculates the
discriminant which tells us whether or
not we hit the sphere at all that's
going to be important to do per sphere
because obviously if we didn't hit the
sphere we don't want to waste time
calculating the rest of this however
over here we have that closest T
variable this is the closest hit
position to the camera this effect
effectively gives us the distance of the
sphere surface that we hit from the
camera we need to make sure that if we
do successfully hit a sphere we do this
calculation for each sphere that we hit
along that Ray and since this gives us
the distance of the hit whichever sphere
Returns the lowest closest T position
that will be the first sphere that Ray
hits and thus that is the only one we
care about evaluating for now after that
we can proceed and calculate the hit
point the normal the light Direction and
the actual sphere color and return it as
an actual pixel color now if you're not
quite understanding all this math then I
highly recommend that you check out the
sponsor of this series and this video
brilliant brilliant is an amazing
website filled with courses on various
stem topics such as like literally all
of the math we'll be using in this Ray
tracing series I get a lot of questions
from programmers asking whether or not
math is important long story short yes
it is but whilst you might be able to
not get 2D deep into math if you work in
other areas of computer science if
you're in graphics programming and like
doing stuff like this Ray tracing series
there's no way you'll get by without
understanding the map and if you do
it'll be very sad whilst brilliant have
a number of advanced math topics such as
calculus which we'll be using later in
this series if you're new to math and
you find it a little bit intimidating
then brilliant have this brand new
everyday math course that you can start
with it's a really nice way to kind of
ease into it before you can move on to
say algebra and then maybe later
calculus now why do I like brilliant so
much why not go to some other Math
course website what makes brilliant
really good in my opinion is the fact
that it's extremely Visual and
interactive seeing how things work
visually is my favorite way to learn I
think a lot of people will probably
agree with that but aside from just
showing things visually so that you can
understand how things work brilliant
also get you to engage with it they give
you these nice controls that you can
play with and once they've taught you
something they quiz you on it to make
sure that you actually understand what's
going on the best thing about brilliant
is you can get started for free just go
to brilliant.org the channel link will
be in the description below and if you
do enjoy it then for the first 200
subscribers brilliant is offering 20 off
an annual membership huge thank you to
brilliant as always for sponsoring this
video so now that we've kind of
determined which part of this math needs
to be done in order to figure out
whether or not we hit a sphere and which
sphere is the closest sphere let's talk
about how we can actually structure a
scene now there's many different ways to
do this and I just want to stress that
like when we learn things in this series
we start off really really gentle we
want to keep this as simple as possible
there's no reason to complicate anything
at this point in time however obviously
we can get fairly complicated and we
probably will as the series goes on
because for example if you have a
thousand spheres in your scene then you
can't simply Loop over every single
sphere to see if if it hits or not that
will be way too slow I mean you can and
of course if this is like a an offline
renderer anyway then maybe waiting 10
minutes or whatever is fine for you but
there are of course faster ways to deal
with larger scenes such as like some
kind of spatial partitioning system if
the camera is facing that way we don't
really care about spheres behind us so
why would we consider them at all we
wouldn't feel free to extend what we've
got here beyond what we're covering in
fact I encourage that it's a really good
exercise obviously however I also want
to keep in mind that because the end
game of this series is to move this onto
the GPU and actually use like Ray
tracing shaders for this stuff I don't
want to spend too much time talking
about like scene side optimization
because the way that we represent this
in acceleration structures later on is
going to mean that we just throw away
all of this code that's not to say we
won't be optimizing the CPU side of this
renderer but just not straight away okay
so let's talk about a scene so what I'm
going to do is if we come over here into
Source let's just add a new item I'm
just going to add a new scene.h header
file and this is simply going to be like
a representation of our scene we're just
going to make a struct called scene
we're going to keep it really simple
it's just going to contain a vector of
spheres and we haven't really defined
our spheres yet so let's go ahead and
also create a struct called sphere and
this is going to contain some kind of
position in 3D space as well as a radius
now I'm going to give it a default
radius of 0.5 so that we have like a one
meter diameter sphere and then I'll also
give it a default position of zero zero
zero so that we're initializing these
variables let's go ahead and include
both glm
and also the vexer header as well and
that is like literally all that we're
going to add because that's all we need
for now actually I lied one more thing I
want to add to this is the color so
let's go ahead and add the color which
we're going to call Albedo why are we
calling color Albedo why not just call
it color because Albedo is technically
like the non-lit diffuse component of a
material and since we'll be kind of
creating a physically based renderer
here we're going to try and use the
correct terms I'm actually going to just
set this to White and actually let's
remove these because we don't need them
okay cool so we have a white sphere that
is one meter in diameter by default at
the origin cool now one thing I want to
do before we kind of move on and create
this this scene here is I actually want
to talk a little bit about the position
of our sphere and how that works because
at the moment we have just been assuming
that the sphere is always at the origin
now our camera can still move around
that's our Ray origin that's the camera
position effectively however what
happens if we want to actually move like
the sphere around how does that work
well if we come back to our math then we
remember that the equation of a circle
is this x minus a squared plus y minus B
squared minus r squared now we only
cared about the X and the Y we only took
X and Y when we plugged everything back
into our actual equation here why did we
do that because A and B represent the
position of this circle or sphere a is
the X component of the position and B is
the Y component of the position and if
we just make those zero then of course x
minus zero y minus zero that just gives
us X and Y and that's good enough to use
now is the time that we have to go back
and actually do this subtraction we need
to do this subtraction before we plug it
into the rest of our equation so that we
can move the sphere somewhere and not
just necessarily have it always in the
origin now you could of course plug this
back into the math equation and work
everything out and that's totally viable
however I think there's an easier way to
think about this problem if this is our
camera that we're rendering everything
from so this is like the origin right
this is our array origin over here and
then we have a sphere but the sphere is
not at the origin like it currently is
let's just say the sphere is over here
this sphere might have like let's just
say we've moved it left so this is like
a top-down view of the camera if we've
moved it left then maybe the x is now
minus two whereas it used to be zero
over here in the origin the thing about
cameras is that cameras don't really
exist they exist in terms of our code
and when we actually calculate the math
like they have to in some form but don't
forget that at the end of the day what
we're actually drawing is pixels on a
screen this screen does not physically
move anywhere all we have to determine
is where objects lie like within this
screen so what I'm trying to say is that
if we have like a sphere in the middle
and we move our camera to the right what
we're actually kind of doing is within
this we're moving the sphere to the left
right because if I draw this sphere over
here again and you pretend this here
doesn't exist anymore it's like the
camera has just moved to the right
because of this because we're really
just translating objects within this
kind of square it doesn't really matter
if our camera is the thing that's doing
the moving or if it's the objects doing
the moving because at the end of the day
the camera just determines which objects
we're looking at and where they are
within our screen so what that means is
if we look at this equation and we take
a look at the ray origin remember the
ray origin is our camera's origin that's
where we shoot race from what happens if
we play with the location of this Ray
origin so instead of firing Rays this
way what if we move the origin somewhere
else say over here and now we just fire
rays that way then check this out our
sphere has like magically transported
into the origin now and that kind of
summarizes how this math is going to
work if our sphere moves to the left by
two units what we need to do is kind of
like move it back in to the origin like
this so that when we look at this
original Ray origin equation here you
can see that this sphere now is back at
zero zero and that is actually what this
like minus a and minus B is doing that's
why it's a minus a and minus B and not
like plus a or something because what
we're doing is if the circle is at like
2 comma two for example that's the
coordinate of the circle we subtract two
from both of these to actually translate
that Circle back into the origin and
it's the exact same concept with our
sphere so basically we just need to take
this Ray origin and subtract the
sphere's origin from it and use that in
place of everywhere that we use our
array origin so let's go ahead and write
glm vect3 origin is going to be like our
new origin and we're just going to write
Ray dot origin minus whatever our sphere
origin is now let's try and translate
that pink sphere to the left by two
units so what I'll do is I'll write glm
effect three maybe actually 0.5 because
I don't know how much will fit onto the
screen 0 and 0 now that's positive 0.5
so that will actually move it right so
let's go ahead and move it left by
writing negative 0.5 here so effectively
we're just adding 0.5 to the X component
of the gray origin and this is the
origin that we're going to use instead
of Ray dot Origins let's go ahead and
replace Ray dot origin with just origin
now let's hit F5 and see if our sphere
is to the left and you can see our
sphere has in fact moved to the left now
some things have happened to the
lighting and the reason for that is
because if we look at the rest of our
code you can see we're still actually
using Ray origin one more time down here
so let's go ahead and replace that with
origin as well and there you go now our
sphere is perfectly lit as it was before
but it's now on the left and just like
that we can move our sphere anywhere we
want in 3D space cool so let's have some
fun with this let's make some kind of
control over here in our UI that will
actually let us translate this sphere in
real time but first let's change our
renderer to work with this new kind of
scene structure because that will enable
it to be aware of all of these
properties if we come back in into this
header file what I'm going to do is
include scene inside renderer.h and then
when we render something what I'm going
to do is actually have it take in a
scene so let's type in const scene
and then cons camera camera now next
episode we're actually going to talk
about the structure of this renderer and
how it's going to work so for now we're
going to stick with this design however
this is going to change completely next
episode I'll also paste in the constant
scene into Trace Rate because we're
going to need this here as well so I'm
not going to have any kind of like
persistent scene inside this class we're
just going to pass it around here into
the required functions let's go ahead
and pass scene over here into Trace Ray
and so now inside Trace Ray we actually
have our scene instance and that
contains all of our spheres so now what
we can do is let's just grab the the
first sphere so first of all if there
are no spheres in the scene so if
scenes.spheres dot size is zero let's go
ahead and return our clear color which
is this because there's literally no
spheres in the scene and then what we'll
do is we'll just grab for now the first
sphere so sphere equals scenes dot
spheres same dot spheres zero and now we
can obviously access the sphere's
position that's what we're doing here as
well as the radius of the sphere which
is what we'll square instead of just
radius so we can delete this 0.5 radius
we were using let's also delete this
right direction we don't need that and
then finally instead of returning Pink
as the sphere color here let's go ahead
and set the sphere color equal to sphere
dot Albedo okay so I think that's all of
the variables the temporary variables we
were using now replaced if we go back
into our main kind of file which is
Walnut app.cpp we can actually add that
scene into here let's go ahead and write
scene and scene it should all be
included because renderer.h includes
scene that's the scene that we're going
to pass into the renderer and let's just
test it out as is so we should just see
a black screen because obviously there
are no spheres to render okay cool we
got a black screen I was just mainly
making sure that it didn't crash or
anything like that over here inside the
Constructor this is where we can set up
our scene so let's go ahead and write
AMC and spheres dot push back and we can
push some kind of sphere into here so
let's go ahead and try and recreate that
same sphere we can just use like an
initialize list to construct this
instance we know it's position radius
Albedo that might make it a little bit
difficult to read so we could set like
the position to say zero then the radius
to 0.5 because that's fine and then we
can make it Pink by writing a code like
this that is a little bit difficult to
read though so you could of course just
write it out normally I'll show you what
normally means in a minute but you can
see we get our sphere so by normally I
mean no no I said normally everything's
normal right but basically what you
could do is just push back a sphere like
this and then just set the parameters
like so so we can set the position to
like zero zero zero obviously so the
radius to whatever you want the
advantage of doing it this way is first
of all you don't need to set all of them
so you can keep you know whichever one
at its default so if you didn't want to
set the radius you can just skip that
and just set like Albedo to for example
pink and then just not set the radius
that's fine but also obviously we have
the names of these variables in these
lines of code whereas here like we have
no idea like is this the translation and
that's the color or maybe it's the other
way around we don't know that's why like
ultimately I would encourage you to kind
of do it this way performance wise in
this case isn't really going to matter
either so I guess let's write it out
this way even though part of me probably
would write it the first way just
because it takes up a little bit less
code a little bit more concise but I
think that this will be better
okay cool and I'll even add the radius
here just so we can see now what I'm
going to do at this point is actually
add some controls so that we can play
around with this inside on UI render we
have a settings panel and that's great
what I want to do is copy it in its
entirety and I'm going to change the
name here to scene and this is just
going to be a nice little panel that we
can dock that will let us control the
Spheres in our scene so let's get rid of
this and what do we really want to
control here well we have three
parameters we have position radius and
Albedo so let's do that let's go ahead
and just add a control for the position
so this will be a drag float three we're
going to give it a label of just
position for now and then glm value
pointer with that sphere dot position
now this also lets us pass in a speed
that's how quick we want to adjust that
value when we actually drag it so I can
type something like 0.1 in and then a
minimum and a maximum we're not really
interested in a minimum and maximum so
we'll just edit that now to use value
pointer you just need to include glm
see and then it's like type pointer like
that and then obviously sphere.position
like What on earth does that mean now
ideally what we would do here is we
would Loop through every single sphere
that we have in our scent we ultimately
only have one for now so let's go ahead
and write scene dot spheres zero for now
we'll change this in a minute just to
test out our position let's go ahead and
also add a control for our radius now
clearly that's not a three component
float so we'll just rename this to be
just a drag float with that single float
we don't need this value pointer instead
we're going to pass the memory address
of radius just like that and we can keep
it at 0.1 sure and then finally our
Albedo which is our color so let's
rename this to be a color edit three
that will give us a nice Color Picker
and then we'll pass in the Albedo like
so okay so we should now be able to
fully edit all of the parameters of that
single sphere that we have
so if we run our program we can see that
we have the scene panel it's brand new
let's go ahead and dock it like up here
maybe I'm just going to go ahead and
resize this a little bit to make it
smaller okay so we have position we have
radius so let's go ahead and try and
move this check this out we can move our
sphere in real time we can make it be
further away with the Z now you'll
notice by the way if I go positive here
we see the sphere but upside down that's
because the way that we're actually
processing like the closest T we're not
really caring about if it's negative and
that's why we kind of see this all you
have to do is just discard the pixel if
that closest to variable is negative but
we'll Implement that a little bit later
but otherwise you can see we can push it
further away move it up and down move it
anywhere we want really everything works
which is great we can make it bigger and
smaller by adjusting this radius which
is pretty cool and then finally we can
play with the Albedo and set it to let
me just move this over here so you guys
can see we can just play with the Albedo
and set the color to whatever we want
okay as simple as that now let's go
ahead and talk about how we can have
multiple spheres so to start this off
what I'm going to do is simply we push
another sphere into here so in order to
have these two kind of spheres here with
the same variable now I'm just going to
add a little scope just like that so
we're pushing back two spheres now at
the moment we're doing this kind of all
manually you probably want to have some
kind of like scene file description
maybe you could also add UI to actually
add these spheres so that you can do it
while the application is running I'll
leave that for you guys to do for
homework but otherwise what I'm going to
do is just push this back a little bit
because I want to kind of make sure that
we get the one sphere in front of
another sphere working correctly so if I
just take this and set it back to like
minus five remember negative Z is the
forward Direction so I'm pushing that
back I might move it like a little bit
maybe to the right and then I'll also
make it be a little bit larger 1.5 and
maybe we'll make it blue so I think I'll
make it like a nice kind of 0.2 0.3 and
one okay cool so we have two spheres now
which one is going to render well if we
look at our code inside the renderer we
obviously know that it's only ever going
to render that first one if we flip back
and just reorder these then we should
see just the blue sphere and that's what
we see okay so it does look like it
would be obscured a little bit by the
pink sphere if we just had like the pink
sphere in front of it as we currently do
so that's good because that's kind of
the result that I'm looking for so now
let's just make this work with multiple
spheres how do we do that well back in
renderer we just need to Loop through
all of these spheres and determine which
of them has the lowest closest T value
so which of these two spheres if we hit
if we hit it at all is the closest
sphere to the camera and then we'll
continue evaluating that so let's go
ahead and write a for Loop here that's
going to go through every single sphere
I'll just write a for each Loop like so
and then this really is going to like
contain the rest of our code but first
we do need to determine whether or not
we hit anything at all and which sphere
is the closest sphere because we
obviously can't evaluate any lighting
until we know which of these spheres is
the closest sphere so let's go ahead and
just make a little pointer here called
closest sphere and I'm going to set it
equal to null pointer this will just
hold like the pointer to whatever sphere
we determine is the closest sphere and
if it's null pointer then we know we
haven't hit anything so then for each
sphere what I'm going to do is go
through basically all of this code right
because we determined this is the code
that needs to be evaluated to work out
our closest hit now if we take a look at
this there's a few things going on here
first of all we're returning we don't
want to return because what what this
will currently do is if we miss the
first sphere then let's say we just
return our clear color but there could
be another sphere we have to Loop
through all of the Spheres in our scene
before we're sure that we didn't hit
anything so because of that if the
discriminant is less than zero all we're
going to do is continue that will just
move us on to like the next sphere now
if we did actually hit something right
so in other words the discriminant here
is greater than zero which means that
we've hit something or is equal to zero
we want to make sure whether or not this
closest T is like the closest so far and
if so then this is in fact our closest
sphere we can't just go ahead and assign
closest sphere to sphere in fact let's
make this a const sphere because
obviously this is now no longer checking
if it's the closest sphere or not this
is just going to set our closest sphere
to be the last sphere that we hit within
this list so what we need to do is kind
of maintain our hit distance over here
we'll set it to like the maximum
possible value for a float which I like
to just type in FLT Max for that you can
use SCD numeric limits float Max like
that and maybe I will do that I don't
know this just takes up so much space
compared to this one little macro that's
just defined to this so honestly that's
why I kind of use it but technically I
guess maybe
so the C plus wealth Community doesn't
kill me this is like the C plus plus way
to do this what I'm doing here is just
setting this hit distance to be again
the maximum possible value of a float
that means that obviously these hit
distances are guaranteed to be less than
that so what I'm going to do here is
just check to see whether or not closest
T is actually less than whatever our
current hit distance is and if it is I'm
going to set closest sphere to sphere
and also update our hit distance with
this closest T and that's all there is
to it now the good thing is we obviously
retain this so we never need to do this
calculation again we've got this hit
distance this is our second hit point
which I'm going to drag up here but
that's not really used so I'm just going
to leave it commented out so that it
doesn't confuse anyone and then since
closest sphere is originally set to null
pointer here we know that if closest
sphere is still null at this point in
time then clearly we haven't hit
anything so if closest sphere equals
null return and will return our glm
effect four zero zero zero
one okay so that's the same thing that
we used to be returning here for this
agreement was less than zero however now
we need to check each discriminant
obviously for each sphere Okay cool so
now what do we have to do well we just
need to continue this calculation
however the sphere that we have here is
now going to be our closest sphere now
we also need origin as you can see if
you scroll up a little bit we do this
calculation up here so we need to do it
again but now it's going to be done for
the closest sphere obviously so if I
come down here and just write origin
we're going to write closest sphere
position like that closest T is going to
be our hit distance and then obviously
sphere Albedo is going to be
close the sphere albeiter like that and
that's kind of it it's really quite
simple so now let's go ahead and run
this code and check it out that's it
let's move our camera around and you can
see we now have
two spheres in 3D space now we can still
only edit one of them so let's go ahead
and fix that if we go back into our main
file here Walnut app I'm going to change
this a little bit so that we actually
iterate through all of the Spheres
inside our scene and I'm going to write
this out as a for Loop you'll see why
later instead of just using a 4H Loop so
M sphere's size I plus plus will
surround all of this inside that for
Loop here and then of course instead of
scene dot spheres and then of course
instead of M C and Dot sphere zero it'll
be mc.sphere's I because I is the index
now I'm actually going to pull this out
a little bit and we're just going to
write sphere sphere equals that that way
I can just kind of create an alias for
it so that I don't have to keep writing
out the full name every time and that
theory of push to work so let's just hit
F5 and see what happens however if I try
and adjust this you can see it actually
adjusts both of the sphere position the
same with like the radius what's going
on here the problem here is actually
with I'm GUI the way that I'm GUI
identifies each control goal is by its
name I mean not necessarily just by its
name but in this case it's identifying
it by its name because these names are
identical per sphere so in other words
as we're iterating through this we're
actually creating two drag floats within
the scene window called position and
when we start interacting with one of
them I'm going to know which one we're
interacting with because they've both
got the same ID to fix this what we can
do all the easiest way probably to fix
this is to just do I'm going push ID and
set kind of like this is almost like
setting like a namespace for this
particular block of controls or widgets
so if we just push ID I and then we pop
it at the end of the iteration
because this I variable is going to be a
unique index for each sphere that means
that this first iteration will kind of
be like position index 0 and then the
next one will be also called position
but it'll be like within index one so it
will have a different ID to make this
look a little bit nicer I'm also going
to go ahead and add a separator between
each iteration so if we launch this now
you can see we have a nice separator
between these and hopefully when we
adjust them it now only adjusts one of
them and we can move this back and forth
we can change like the color to whatever
we want the radius and you can see we
can have a nice big one here and more or
less we have multiple spheres rendering
in our scene now our render time has of
course increased because now we're
shading more pixels and we also have to
evaluate more potential spheres but hey
that's life there are some optimizations
we can do already to the math so go
ahead and maybe try and explore those if
you're interested just try and look at
the code and see if you can come up with
anything doesn't necessarily need to be
done potentially but otherwise next time
will be a bit of a restructuring episode
we're going to talk about how we can
kind of scale this a little bit because
we're doing everything inside that one
Trace Ray function that's going to make
things in the future a little bit more
difficult and also I want to structure
things in a way that's going to be a
little bit more like the GPU way that we
end the series with so thank you guys
for watching hope you enjoyed this
episode of the ray tracing series don't
forget that every episode is pushed to
GitHub in a separate command so all of
the code is available there for free for
you guys to check out go ahead and brush
up on your math and support the series
by going to brilliant.org the channel
and I will see you guys next time
goodbye
foreign
[Music]